miles de ciudadanos chinos estaban
ansiosos por volver a subirse a un avión
hay mucha gente saliendo con la
relajación de la política Cero covid en
China muchos países asiáticos esperan
con anhelo la llegada de turistas
procedentes del gigante asiático
contrario de occidente donde más de una
docena de países impusieron
restricciones sanitarias a Los viajeros
procedentes de china en Tailandia Japón
o Indonesia los comerciantes se preparan
para la llegada de turistas que ya no
tendrán que pasar largas cuarentenas en
hoteles como antes y paliar así los
efectos negativos para sus economías por
la pandemia
antes de la pandemia teníamos muchos
frentes chinos casi todas las cafeterías
que trabajan con agentes turísticos
chinos estaban llenas venían al menos
entre 100 y 200 clientes al día
antes había tantos clientes chinos que
estamos agradecidos por su regreso y su
contribución a nuestras ventas
se encuentra en un camino de vuelta a la
normalidad Pese a que los hospitales
Siguen copados con pacientes contagiados
de covid y cada vez más naciones de
Europa América y África toman medidas
para evitar rebrotes masivos en sus
territorios
el centro europeo de control y
prevención de enfermedades y otras
instituciones profesionales han dicho
que no razonable imponer restricciones a
los pasajeros procedentes de China la
Unión Europea debería Escuchar estas
voces racionales y tratar la situación
de la epidemia en China de forma
objetiva y justa el próximo 8 de enero
el país asiático reabrirá sus fronteras
por primera vez desde marzo del 2020